As Hollywood gears up for the 2018 blockbuster
season, movie studios are throwing out new
trailers right and left.
February alone saw new glimpses of Infinity
War, Deadpool 2, Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom,
and so much more.
It's hard to keep track of everything that's
worth watching, so we rounded up the best
February movie trailers that are sure to blow
you away.
"Oh, wow. That was unrealistically fast. Okay, hit it."
The Hurricane Heist
The ultimate storm meets the perfect heist
in The Hurricane Heist, an action extravaganza
about a group of thieves who plan to rob the
U.S. Treasury in the middle of a category
five hurricane.
Appropriately, The Scorpions' "Rock You Like
a Hurricane" forms the musical backdrop to
a crazy montage of thievery and stormy weather.
"Just say here and let's consider the word
to be short for "here I am, rock you like
a hurricane."
"You do as the Scorpions have before you!"
Coming from director Rob Cohen of xXx and
The Fast and the Furious, it's bound to be
an action-packed ride.
Look for it on March 9th.
The Outsider
Jared Leto is in top form in the trailer for
The Outsider, a Netflix film that will be
arriving in early March.
Leto plays Nick Lowell, an American soldier
held captive in Japan at the end of World
War II.
In exchange for his freedom, he has to join
the yakuza and adopt their way of life, no
matter how much blood he has to shed.
Take a look on March 9th.
Gringo
Amazon Studios dropped the final trailer for
their dark comedy Gringo in February, adding
even more excitement to what already looked
like a funny, action-filled tale.
Representing a U.S. medical company, a naive
businessman travels to a factory in Mexico
to deliver the formula for a new high-tech
cannabis pill.
Unfortunately, he also becomes a target for
a drug cartel.
Wacky, murderous hijinks ensue.
Gringo stars David Oyelowo, Joel Edgerton,
and Charlize Theron, and premieres on March
9th.
Pacific Rim: Uprising
Even though Guillermo del Toro isn't returning
to helm Pacific Rim: Uprising, the trailers
so far at least have us hoping that it'll
preserve the magic of the first film.
That is to say, it better be mostly about
giant robots duking it out with giant monsters.
"That's what I'm talking about."
With February's IMAX trailer, it's looking
more and more like the filmmakers behind Pacific
Rim: Uprising understand what made its predecessor
cheesy and wonderful.
It's full of useless inspirational speeches,
people shouting, and robots with swords.
One of the Kaiju gets a Mechagodzilla upgrade.
This is all good stuff.
As long as the movie doesn't try to make us
care too much about Stacker's son, consider
us pumped.
Check it out on March 23rd.
Ready Player One
For a movie that's mostly going to be a giant
game of spot the nostalgia, Ready Player One
is starting to look like one of the most visually
interesting blockbusters of the year.
Two trailers for the movie were released in
February.
The first shows more general footage, but
the second reveals the basic plotline for
those who don't already know it.
A voiceover explains that there are three
keys that open three gates, and whoever finds
them all wins a prize.
That prize is trillions of dollars left behind
by the creator of the virtual reality world
OASIS, and the entire story is about one kid
trying to find all the keys before anyone
else.
Look for it on March 29th.
The Titan
Starring Sam Worthington as a soldier selected
to become one of the first humans on Titan,
Saturn's largest moon, The Titan looks like
a sleek action sci-fi experience.
In the trailer, we see Worthington's character
undergo a genetic experiment that transforms
him into a freaky, white-skinned monster — clearly,
there were a few unintended side effects.
The Titan will premiere on Netflix on March
30th, so you won't even have to leave the
house for this one.
The Last Movie Star
Burt Reynolds headlines The Last Movie Star
as an aging actor who's being honored with
a lifetime achievement award.
What he doesn't know is that the award is
being presented in a run-down bar in Tennessee.
"Let's get you over to the red carpet."
The experience prompts him to go on a journey
of self-discovery.
It looks like an emotional film with one of
the best actors of the generation, and well
worth checking out on March 30.
A Quiet Place
After cutting his directing teeth on the 2016
romcom The Hollars, John Krasinski is back
behind the camera for A Quiet Place, a unique
twist on the horror genre about mysterious
monsters that hunt down anyone they can hear.
Krasinski and Emily Blunt star as two parents
trying to keep their family safe in this freaky
new world.
The trailer doesn't reveal much beyond the
initial setup, although we know that the creatures
came via some kind of invasion and Emily Blunt's
character is pregnant, which is bound to lead
to a tense childbirth scene.
Find out on April 6th.
10x10
For the true romantics out there, there's
nothing like a little kidnapping to get you
in the mood for Valentine's Day.
Released on February 13th, this trailer sees
Luke Evans starring as a man who abducts a
woman and locks her in a padded room in his
house.
His motives are unclear, but the trailer hints
that there may be a deeper connection between
these two people.
"Why are you doing this?
I think you already know."
10x10 looks like a thrilling psychological
study, and a welcome change of pace as we
head into blockbuster season.
Look for it on April 13th.
Marrowbone
If a horror trailer that isn't jammed full
of jump scares sounds like an interesting
twist, you'll definitely want to check out
the trailer for Marrowbone.
Four recently orphaned children hide out in
their family's abandoned estate to keep the
state from separating them, only to find out
that the crumbling house may actually be haunted.
It's The Boxcar Children crossed with The
Shining, and it features a fantastic cast
of up-and-coming actors, including Stranger
Things' Charlie Heaton, Split's Anya Taylor-Joy,
and Captain Fantastic's George MacKay.
Experience all the thrills on April 13th.
Rampage
Starring Dwayne Johnson, Jeffrey Dean Morgan,
and lots of CGI, Rampage is bound to be the
year's biggest movie about giant fighting
monsters that isn't Pacific Rim.
Judging by the trailer, it's going to be a
pretty faithful adaptation of the 1986 arcade
game, plus bonus material in the form of all
the human characters and the whole "story"
part.
At least the three main characters are all
present — George, the enormous gorilla;
Lizzie, the Godzilla thing; and Ralph, the
radioactive wolf who can fly if he eats the
right toxic sludge.
"Of course the wolf flies."
Rampage will be tearing up the box office
on April 20th.
Batman Ninja
DC's cinematic universe may leave a lot to
be desired, but the company has always made
solid animated films, and Batman Ninja looks
like another amazing entry.
A freak energy surge sends Batman back in
time to feudal Japan — along with a ton
of villains, including the Joker, Harley Quinn,
Deathstroke, and Gorilla Grodd.
Batman will have to stop them from rewriting
history if he wants to save the future.
Yeah, it sounds as awesome as it looks.
Look for it on streaming sites on April 24th.
Avengers: Infinity War
At this point, there's no way the hype for
Infinity War can get any bigger, but the newly
released Super Bowl trailer definitely makes
a bid to change that.
Featuring even more shots of Earth's Mightiest
Heroes and their franchise pals preparing
for war against Thanos, the entire trailer
is tailor-made to make fans' hearts pound.
"Let's go."
Not that we're complaining.
We'll take every piece of Infinity War footage
Marvel wants to give us leading up to the
film's May 4th release.
Deadpool 2
Hands down the most hilarious trailer from
February is the "Deadpool, Meet Cable" trailer
for Deadpool 2.
While it starts out like a typical teaser,
it switches gears just a few seconds in and
becomes much more, well, Deadpool.
"Wait, no, stop.
What in the actual ass?"
So Wade takes matters into his own hands and
stages his own action-packed reveal with Cable
and Deadpool action figures.
After that bit, however, the trailer picks
up again, giving fans their first look at
Cable in action, and it's amazing.
We're also given glimpses of some of the new
mutants taking on the shadowy DMC.
And of course, all the familiar faces are
back.
It'll be hard to top the first movie, but
judging by this trailer, it just may happen
on May 18th.
Solo: A Star Wars Story
The first teaser trailer for Solo: A Star
Wars Story was met with mixed reactions.
Some fans are looking forward to seeing Alden
Ehrenreich stepping in as a young Han Solo,
while others were left saying:
"I got a bad feeling about this…"
Filled with in-jokes from the original films
and cloying glimpses of everything from the
Millenium Falcon to Donald Glover's Lando,
the trailer is definitely a treat for the
eyes.
Whether the film itself leaves the same impression
remains to be seen on May 25th.
Incredibles 2
It's been 14 long years since The Incredibles
first hit theaters, so you better believe
the release of the Incredibles 2 trailer was
an earth-shattering event — and not just
because The Underminer is back.
Fortunately, it looks like it was worth the
wait.
The trailer focuses on Mr. Incredible staying
home with the kids while Elastigirl goes off
on a mission, leading to all the jokes you
could ask for involving a stay-at-home dad
with unruly superpowered kids.
"But I can't keep giving him cookies.
No biting daddy!"
Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom
While the first trailer offered a glimpse
of Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom back in
2017, the newly released trailer is bigger,
bolder, and more Jurassic.
When a dormant volcano on Jurassic World threatens
to erupt, Owen and Claire head back to the
island to rescue their prehistoric friends.
But dinosaurs will be dinosaurs, those silly
goofs, so they're still set on eating Owen
and Claire and everybody else made of meat.
"You need to get us out of here."
Will the heroic duo be able to save the dinosaurs
before it's too late?
And more importantly, will saving them put
the rest of the world in danger?
We'll find out on June 22nd.
Skyscraper
The only things bigger than Dwayne Johnson's
biceps are the movies he's starring in these
days.
Skyscraper marks yet another high-octane blockbuster
release for Johnson in 2018, and it's filled
with enough machine guns, explosions, and
gravity-defying antics to get any action fan
excited.
Take the plunge on July 13th.
Mission: Impossible — Fallout
Counter to the way most franchises operate,
the Mission: Impossible series just keeps
getting better.
This time, Ethan Hunt and his gang of spies
have to deal with some kind of nuclear threat,
and Hunt may have been betrayed...again.
But where the trailer plays coy on plot reveals,
it revels in its own self-awareness and glorious
stunts — like stealing a helicopter in mid-air
and doing a barrel roll.
Which, per Cruise tradition, all actually
happened.
"Same old Ethan."
And that wasn't even the craziest stunt Tom
Cruise pulled for the movie.
"I knew I broke it instantly."
"Two down."
"Well anyone else would go, well that's over,
NO.
Up he gets, and he's running!"
He just runs away on a broken foot, gotta
catch those bad guys.
Superman is literally in the movie, and Tom
Cruise still manages to out-Superman him.
Give this madman an Oscar already.
Venom
The internet spent a solid year champing at
the bit for their first glimpse of Tom Hardy
as Venom, and now...well, we're still waiting.
Despite not actually showing Venom, the film's
first trailer does introduce Hardy's character,
Eddie Brock, in his human form, apparently
after an accident that landed him in the hospital.
From there, we see a few vague action scenes
and a brief glimpse of something black and
symbiote-y writhing in a tank — before the
trailer takes us back to hospitalized Hardy
freaking out while a few black veins creep
up his neck.
Honestly, we could have waited another month
for a better trailer, but this one did the
job of whetting our appetite for the eventual
big reveal.
Which...will come, right?
Eventually?
Hopefully, before the movie's October 5th
release.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!